we really shouldn't be doing this adams argued
it's fine it's just a test his fellow researcher
burton retorted in protest the containment
procedures for scp-914 come with a very specific
warning not to test biological matter in it if
anyone had found out what we were doing we would
both be fired or worse dosed up with amnestics and
left on a sidewalk somewhere with no clue who we
were burton rolled their eyes adam's concern was
hardly unfounded but when they had discussed the
idea earlier he'd seemed open to it then again
it was only a hypothetical back then now it was
getting closer to becoming reality look aren't you
tired of what we do here burton argued indignantly
so many of the tests we run end up with dead
d-class personnel blood everywhere or just end
up creating new anomalies that will just only
go on to cause more people to die i'm sick of
it i don't think this course of action is the
best solution to that though their colleague
urged why not as cp 2800 is one of the few
anomalies either of us have ever encountered
that we can categorically consider to be good
he's not some heartless monster or vengeful
cosmic deity he just wants to do the right thing
i already mentioned it to him he's more than happy
to undergo the change and what if it kills him
adams asked no what if it works burton responded
sidestepping that possibility entirely worst case
scenario he might not survive sure but best case
we could turn an ineffectual would-be superhero
into a tool to do some real lasting good the
pair of researchers went back and forth until
ultimately adams conceded it was hard to deny
that throwing any number of other scps into the
clockwork refinement machine known as scp-914
would easily yield far more destructive results
but scp-2800 was as burton rightfully pointed
out a being of well-meaning intentions if any
average person were to wake up to find their
body had developed characteristics consistent
with that of a saguaro cactus they'd likely seek
out immediate medical assistance but when that
happened to daniel mcintyre he immediately sought
to use his newfound condition and the anomalous
abilities it granted him to offer assistance
to any person that needed it as the superhero
cactus man the spiked menace unfortunately when
intervening in situations daniel proved himself
to be somewhat ineffectual as a hero although
this didn't deter him from trying now housed in
containment under the designation scp-2800 cactus
man still continued to offer assistance to the
staff of the scp foundation his behavior came as
the result of a few diagnosed psychological
conditions particularly his hero complex a
deep-rooted desire to help others no matter the
personal cost to daniel himself and it was this
part of him that caused scp-2800 to wholeheartedly
agree to researcher burton's test unaware that
the experiment had not been sanctioned by the
wider foundation over here cactus men asked as
he stepped into the booth labeled intake following
researcher adam's directions that's perfect 2800
the researcher replied offering a thumbs up before
he turned away hiding his look of concern shall we
start with the one-to-one setting researcher
burton the hell with that burton scoff we've
got maybe one attempt at this before security
notices he's out of his cell and come here to find
out what we're up to we go big or we go home i'm
setting 914 to very fine burton strode over to the
machine and threw the dial to the highest of its
five settings turning the key below it wound the
mainspring and the entire device churned into life
the door to the intake booth sliding shot gears
were spinning and grinding the complex contraption
of over 8 million moving parts starting its
refinement process belts pulleys gears springs
and scp-914's other clockwork parts all began
clicking and clacking well scp-2800 stood in
the intake booth growing more and more uneasy
at all the noise this strange machine was making
although the foundation had little idea how its
refinement process worked scp-914 seemed to take
any object placed within its intake compartment
and disassemble recreate improve or destroy the
item depending on the setting its control knob
was switched to ruff completely obliterated an
intake object on a molecular level reducing it
to little more than dust coarse dismantled the
target into its base components while one to
one replaced it with a similar item of matching
design size and quality the next setting up find
would improve upon the base item although usually
without granting it any anomalous properties and
very fine well you can figure it out from there
you're smart the last time a living being had been
placed in scp-914 on the very fine setting it had
been a d-class and the results were catastrophic
a massive containment failure numerous casualties
including the test subject since then no testing
of biological matter was permitted in scp-914 but
burton was convinced that scp-2800's innate need
to help people his deep-seated hero complex and
generally kind nature would mean that the outcome
was worth breaking the rules scp-914 was ticking
and worrying the noises of its components getting
louder and louder with each passing second so
loud in fact that it drowned out the approaching
clump of foundation issue boots freeze hands in
the air yelled one of the security team as they
burst into research cell 109-b where the machine
was housed the pair of guards assigned to watch
it laid tied up and unconscious on the floor both
researcher burton and adams threw their hands up
as instructed struck with panic at being caught in
the act the foundation security personnel moved in
restraining them clasping handcuffs tightly
around the two researchers wrists suddenly
the noise of the machine stopped the guards all
turned their attention to scp-914 raising their
weapons training them on the output booth with
no idea what was about to step out timidly as
the compartment door slid open cactus man slowly
emerged looking around confused as far as burton
could tell from looking scp-2800 didn't appear to
be any different he cursed adams under his breath
irrationally believing that he'd somehow changed
the machine's setting to one to one during all
the commotion that is until one of the guards
approached cactus man to restrain him as the
security officer moved to cuff him scp-2800's arm
whipped around as if of its own accord with the
speed and precision of someone with far more
hand-to-hand combat training that daniel had
ever received cactus man gently yet firmly swatted
the foundation's guard's hands away and turned him
around it had been so easy so instinctive that
scp-2800 looked even surprised himself barely
able to believe the movements of his own prickly
plant-based body the guard tried to raise his arms
again only to find he couldn't it was completely
numb in fact everywhere scp-2800 had touched while
deflecting him was the same a series of long sharp
cactus needles from daniel had been embedded in
the security officer's uniform piercing through
his clothing and skin all the way to his muscles
and yet it was painless he could hardly feel any
of the sharp protrusions cactus man had disabled
him with such effectiveness that the pain didn't
even register his spines implanted in the guard's
body like acupuncture needles then seeing what he
had done with an instinctive flick of his wrist
scp-2800 made the spikes withdraw from the officer
and they shot back through the air reattaching
themselves to his body following the incident and
a severe reprimand for their unauthorized use of
scp-914 researcher burton was assigned to reassess
scp-2800's new improved abilities the goal behind
his investigation was to determine whether cactus
man had now been rendered a more useful asset
for the foundation given he had retained his
need to offer help to others they were looking
to make use of him sure enough the existing
anomalous abilities daniel had exhibited before
his refinement seemed to have become much more
formidable powers scp-2800 had greater control
over the growing of his prickly spines as shown
when he first emerged from scp-914 not only could
he detach them at will as he could before but he
seemingly gained an instinctive power to launch
them as high-speed projectiles neither recall
them or regrow missing spines at an accelerated
rate on top of that his reflexes seemed to have
greatly improved as had his fighting prowess
now able to take on multiple adversaries
without one of them ever landing a hit on
him his cactacarous retention of water making him
able to survive on around one third of the water
needed by an average human male was also improved
now scp-2800 could survive on next to no water
without drying out even a few drops was enough to
sustain him for an extended period additionally no
external factor could cause him to lose water his
plant cells were retaining even being in a high
temperature environment his resistance to high
temperatures typical of many plants within the
cacti family had now evolved into scp-2800 being
fireproof he was unable to catch a light even
after direct exposure to flame additionally he had
previously been able to empathetically connect and
communicate with other cacti often causing them
to increase their water and nutrient absorption
now though cactus man could cause his fellow
spiked plants to rapidly grow at an exponential
rate even producing cacti seeds that he could
command to grow the instant they made contact
with the soil or absorbed moisture retained
by his own body despite the rules broken to
refine him the foundation now had their very own
plant-powered superhero ready to be deployed at
a moment's notice in the event of a containment
breach and more than happy to help and it couldn't
have happened at a more opportune time over the
coming years the foundation granted permission
for cactus man to assist in various recontainment
efforts when dangerous anomalies broke free of
their cells he ended up preventing the deaths
of a lot of the foundation's mobile task force
operatives as well as their various personnel
purely by intervening so they didn't have to
put themselves in jeopardy however it was the
eventual defeat of scp-682 that allowed daniel to
really make a name for himself as the full-blown
superhero he'd always wanted to be nobody was sure
how it happened all that really mattered was the
monstrous hard to destroy reptile was loose again
the crocodilian creature famous for despising
all other forms of life had torn through the
foundation facility where it was being kept it
left a trail of destruction in its wake causing
multiple subsequent containment breaches and
while the foundation mobilized its forces to try
to limit the damage and re-establish containment
of the various anomalies now freed scp-682 was
making its way towards civilization only to find
cactus man the spiked menace standing in its path
the monstrous lizard snarled at the sight of what
it viewed as such a pathetic adversary even plant
life especially a sentient humanoid plant was an
abhorrent abomination to scp-682 civilians were
running in terror of the hard to destroy reptile
as it made its way through the city slaughtering
any in its path and yet scp-2800 was standing
bravely against it we both know they'll catch
up to you eventually daniel called to the monster
as soon as they'll do it'll be right back in the
vat of acid with ye i know you're not a fan of
being locked up i'm not either but you need to
go back to your cage scp-682 started laughing
a roaring inhuman sound it didn't feel the
part planned creature was even worth a verbal
response suit yourself pal cactus man smirked
he started calmly walking towards the beast
as scp-682 began charging its way through the
street hurtling towards its enemy still as cp 2800
strode without breaking a sweat not that a cactus
can sweat but whereas before he would have doubted
himself especially going up against something as
big and ferocious as the hard to destroy reptile
now daniel was cool and collected with two seeds
in his palm they quickly grew into round spiked
cacti that covered his clenched fists like boxing
gloves with sharp pointed needles sticking out of
them scp-682 was almost upon him and launched a
vicious swipe with its clawed arm moving with
speed and the matrix-like reflexes cactus man
easily sidestepped the oncoming blow before 682
had time to launch another attack 2800 countered
with a cactacrous counter move he gave a series
of quick jabs each strike of his fist landing
with enough strength to reel the crocodilian
creature and leave sharp spines embedded in
its snout the hard to destroy reptile backed up
trying to create some distance between it and its
surprisingly strong opponent but cactus man wasn't
about to let this monster get another chance to
attack raising both arms he fired a volley of
his cactus spines at the monstrosity the barrage
of razor-sharp needles shredding through the
reptile's flesh more were regrowing in the place
of the ones now tearing through scp-682 supplying
daniel with an infinite supply of spikes to shoot
at the reptile as fast as it could regenerate
from the damage suddenly still being impaled
by the bombardment of needles the crocodilian
anomaly gave a wild flailing swipe of its arm the
monster's claws cleaved ruts into cactus man's
chest the aggressive move caught him off guard
for a split second just enough time for scp-682
to thrash its tail and sent him hurtling across
the street cactus man crashed into the sidewalk
with enough force to crack the pavement knocking
down a lamppost and uprooting a fire hydrant
water was spraying up into the air as he tried
to will himself to get back up struggling with
his lack of arms until the cool spray of water
came raining down on daniel and instantly he felt
rejuvenated it was stronger and more invigorating
than any sip of coffee or energy drink on the
market absorbing sunlight and moisture he renewed
his literal green fingers with more newly formed
spines protruding through his chlorophyll-filled
skin in seconds cactus man was back to full form
ready to end this fight once and for all turning
to face the sinister scaly terror that was scp-682
daniel nelton reached his hand into the cracks he
had left in the asphalt his fingers reached deeper
right into the soil below while scp-682 began to
menacingly draw nearer it charged again only to
feel a rumbling burrowing up through the very
earth beneath its feet until suddenly something
came bursting up from the ground sending chunks
of road up into the air overturning nearby cars
with the force of whatever was exploding up from
below sharp piercing pain ripped through the heart
to destroy reptile's body at multiple points its
arms legs torso were all impaled whatever it was
kept burrowing upwards lifting scp-682 up off the
ground as it climbed no grew out of the earth
a gigantic cactus had sprouted up seemingly out
of nowhere it was huge far bigger than any on
record the size of a large oak tree and still
rapidly growing its spiked branches reached
outwards as it climbed and climbed pulling
apart the limbs of scp-682 that were impaled on
its enormous needles separated into several angry
snarling and thrashing pieces the hard to destroy
reptile was bested all the while scp-2800 was
concentrating on endlessly regrowing the spines
of its miles tall cactus he had created keeping
scp-682 skewered long enough for the foundation to
move in and recontain the infamous creature crowds
of people had witnessed the battle and filmed
it on their phones some even live streaming the
showdown as it happened by the time the foundation
was about to initiate a cover-up and start
administering amnestics the name cactus man was
already trending worldwide on social media news
crews flocked to the scene rushing up to thank
scp-2800 for his heroism people were cheering and
clapping in their gratitude and what's more when
fire crews and emergency services began tending to
those wounded in the reptilian rampage daniel was
seen aiding them he helped clear rubble using his
plant powers clearing damaged vehicles and debris
from buildings and offering to help paramedics
tend to the wounded all this while watched by
the adoring eyes of the people he wanted to save
it was too late for the foundation to step in
and sweep this incident under the rug the whole
world had seen cactus man now and they loved him
of course that didn't stop them from trying to
recontain scp-2800 but when shady vehicles and
armored mtf troops appeared to whisk their new
hero away people didn't take kindly to it even
while unaware of who the foundation was or what
they did there was a massive public outcry for
cactus man to be released from whoever had taken
him into custody the foundation did their best to
ignore it placing daniel back in his cell for the
time being that was until the worldwide calls of
free cactus man grew so loud that even the powers
that be started to listen the governments of the
world slowly all started sharing their own support
of the plant-powered hero who had risked his life
for the safety of ordinary citizens he'd never
even met there were some who blamed the immense
collateral damage caused by his fight with scp-682
on daniel himself especially with a gigantic
skyscraper-sized cactus permanently standing on
the site where the battle took place however those
detractors were eventually silenced by those with
the growing concern of who would protect them if
an incident like that ever happened again finally
the scp foundation were put under enough immense
unignorable pressure by the governments of every
country that knew of their existence that there
was only one course of action left the door to
daniel mcintyre was unlocked and open for good
and cactus man was free to go the world welcomed
him with open arms he was awarded medals for
bravery thanks to his efforts in saving people
by fending off 682. cactus man graciously accepted
and offered to help out wherever he could anywhere
in the world over the coming years working with
intelligence and transportation provided by the
foundation scp-2800 was sent anywhere and
everywhere wherever there was conflict or
a natural disaster or even another containment
breach the world had a hero ready and willing to
step in people adored daniel with many growing
varieties of cacti in their homes to honor his
heroics and just in case he ever needed backup
should the worst happen cactus man had become
a hero beyond his own wildest aspirations but
despite being adored and revered the world over
saving lives was never about fame or recognition
to him the fact remained that daniel just couldn't
help it even before being put inside scp-914
and refined he had always held doing the right
thing above all else no matter the impact it had
on himself he'd risk his own safety risk being
beaten up injured or worse if it meant getting
another person out of harm's way commendable
some might say but that compulsion never left
him even after ushering in a new era of peace
scp-2800 still wanted to help save people but was
there anybody left who needed him to well there
was just one man one cactus man who still needed
saving now go and check out what if scp-343 wore
scp-035 and homelander vs the scp foundation
for more weird and wild what-if scenarios